so I've got three suggestions for who we
ought to topple now that we're taken
down Thomas Jefferson and Christopher
Columbus and Aunt Jemima first one Karl
Marx Karl Marx the founder of communism
and the author of the racist
anti-semitic tract on the Jewish
Question here's just a little quote from
that tract
what is the secular basis of Judaism
practical needs self-interest
what is the worldly religion of the Jew
Huck stirring what is this worldly God
money very well then emancipation from
Huck stirring and money consequently
from practical real Judaism would be the
self emancipation of our time an
organization of society which would
abolish the preconditions for Huck
stirring and therefore the possibility
of Huck stirring would make the Jew
impossible that sounds politically
incorrect to me that sounds like a guy
that probably we should cancel so if
we're gonna be cancelling people first
one on my list Karl Marx second one on
my list Margaret Sanger there are
actually statues to Margaret Sanger in
the United States one of them is in the
Smithsonian Margaret Sanger a eugenicist
Margaret Sanger very bad woman Margaret
Sanger very possibly a racist she's the
author of a better race through birth
control she writes the most important
problem
barring none that confronts humanity
today is that of race culture it has
often been said and never with more
truth than at the present time that man
breeds his cattle with more intelligence
and care than he breeds his own kind the
draft figures alone should be sufficient
to galvanize the human race to action
for the intelligence tests made on our
soldiers during the recent war indicated
approximately 25% of our population
never attains a mentality superior to
that of a twelve-year-old when we
consider that the mentally deficient
reproduce more rapidly than those of
normal intelligence we may well look
into the future with dismay unless a
halt is called and that speedily are
racist doomed to inevitable
deterioration
sounds pretty ablest to me where I
probably should cancel Margaret Sanger
she writes in the eugenics value of
birth control propaganda that the issue
here are mental deficiency white which
she has this obsession with people who
have a low IQ and she just wants to get
rid of them unfortunately many
modern-day eugenicist smen even work at
Planned Parenthood think the same thing
and of course there's a deep
relationship between Margaret Sanger and
Planned Parenthood and then in a 1930
line 9 letter Sanger writes we do not
want word to go out that we want to
exterminate the Negro population and the
minister is the man who can straighten
out that idea if it ever occurs to any
of their more rebellious members look I
think we got to pull those statutes down
don't we my final suggestion for the
canceled mob Che Guevara you know Che
Guevara communist revolutionary and
frequent subject of liberal t-shirts
che Guevara writes in the motorcycle
diaries the blacks those magnificent
examples of the African race who have
maintained their racial purity thanks to
their lack of an affinity with bathing
have seen their territory invaded by a
new kind of slave the Portuguese the
black is indolent and a dreamer spending
his meager wage on frivolity or drink
the European has a tradition of work and
saving which has pursued him as far as
this corner of America and drives him to
advance himself even independently of
his own individual aspirations so it
sounds a little racist to me for
canceling Jefferson and Columbus
probably got a canceled Shea who writes
in the diaries of the Revolutionary War
in Congo given the prevailing lack of
discipline it would have been impossible
to use Congolese machine-gunners to
defend the base from air attack they did
not know how to handle their weapons and
did not want to learn very rough stuff I
think we got to take those statues down
either we take no statues down or we
definitely take those statues down and
get a little silver lining in this storm
cloud of mayhem that we're living
through right now
[Music]
you
[Music]